3h30
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles et
dans cette émission nous allons aller en
turquie toujours coincés aux portes de
l'europe
une procédure d'adhésion est en cours
mais cela reste un sujet de controverse
majeure surtout lorsque l'on part
l'élargissement et l'actualité de la
semaine c'est l'europe qui vient de
lever l'embargo sur les armes aux
rebelles syriens
nous tenterons de voir si ce qui est
présenté comme une solution ne risque
pas au contraire d'envenimer encore un
peu plus le conflit syrien
après plusieurs heures de négociations
les ministres des affaires étrangères
européens sont enfin tombés d'accord
ça y est après plusieurs semaines de
tergiversations d'annonce de démentis il
lève l'embargo sur la livraison d'armes
aux rebelles syriens
pas trop tôt en en deux ans de conflit
armé près de 100000 morts et depuis
quelques jours la preuve que bachar
el-assad utilisent des armes chimiques
contre son propre peuple
mais derrière cette déclaration c'est
une autre réalité aucune livraison ne
pourra se faire avant le 1er août le
temps à la diplomatie russe ou
américaine de faire son travail lors
d'une conférence prévue en juin
un délai qui désespère les représentants
de l' armée syrienne libre forcément
dégât collatéral cette décision a pointé
une nouvelle fois la cacophonie qui
règne dans le rang des diplomaties
européennes 27 pays
27 ministres des affaires étrangères 27
lignes et un service d'action extérieure
piloté par lady ashton
incapable d'organiser un front commun
alors les européens sont ils condamnés à
la cacophonie
alors notre invité aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau et arnaud danjean bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen
français vous êtes du groupe ppe c'est à
dire dont la droite ici au parlement
européen
et vous êtes également le président de
la sous-commission sécurité et défense
quelle est votre première réaction après
la levée de cet embargo sur les armes
aux rebelles syriens
je pense que c'est une mauvaise décision
je pense que c'est une décision qui est
une forme de demi mesure parce que nous
savons tous que la vraie alternative
elle est entre l'intervention militaire
qui est juridiquement militairement
techniquement impossible en tout cas
très compliqué et l'action strictement
diplomatique et politique mais qui ne
donne pas beaucoup de résultats je vous
le concède est donc entre ces deux
alternatives nous choisissons une voie
médiane
j'allais dire un peu hypocrite qui sert
à nous donner bonne conscience on lève
un embargo sur les armes qui ne sera une
lever l'embargo qui ne sera pas décisive
qui ne changera pas de façon décisive l'
équilibre des forces sur le terrain et
qui comporte surtout beaucoup d'effets
pervers possible déstabilisation de la
région
armement de personnes que nous ne
souhaitons pas armés bref beaucoup
allaient faire puisque vous dites
l'intervention sur le terrain n'est pas
possible
oui elle salamanca et la saison
difficile est-ce qu'il faut rien faire
il ya 100 millions 800 mille morts
une somme énorme enfin c'est pas
forcément notre responsabilité première
des fonctionnaires nous ne sommes pas
responsables de tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde et je crois pas que nous
ayons une responsabilité plus forte dans
le conflit syrien que dans d'autres
conflits
cela étant il ne faut pas à rien faire
mais tout le monde dit que la solution
en syrie et les politiques nous voyons
d'ailleurs que des efforts diplomatiques
sont faits actuellement par les russes
et les américains pour avoir une
conférence que nous appelons de nos
voeux depuis longtemps donc il faut
mettre le paquet sur la solution
politique
est-ce qu'on peut s'aventurer au delà de
cette recherche de solutions politiques
je conçois j'allais dire moralement la
difficulté de l'inaction
pour autant faut-il se lancer dans des
les actions dont on n'est pas certains
des effets et des dommages collatéraux
qu'elle peuvent produire moi je suis
très sceptique
est ce que vous auriez dit la même chose
si ça avait été un gouvernement de
droite en france qui avait pris cette
décision
oui parce qu'il ya des personnalités de
droite éminente je pense notamment à
alain juppé qui sont plutôt favorables à
cette levée de l'embargo donc c'est pas
une ligne qui a à voir avec la politique
française c'est une considération
j'allais dire de de l'enjeu syrien
lui-même de l'enjeu régional
et puis une façon par rapport à des à ce
type de crises aussi d'établir une
politique vous savez les lever l'embargo
sur les armes
moi j'y suis par principe assez réticent
parce que d'abord je considère que dans
chaque conflit beaucoup d'armes
je crois que la syrie n'échappe pas à la
règle est-ce qui a déjà des armes par
exemple parce qu'en fait la france en
fait la france et la grande bretagne
soit 1.1 sur ce dossier je pense que là
je pense pas et ce qu'il est ce qu est
ce qu on en livre déjà
non je pense pas que la france et la
grande-bretagne livre des armes en
violant l'embargo exactement ce qui est
ce qui est vraisemblable comme dans tous
les conflits c'est que nous fermions les
yeux sur des livraisons d'armes qui ont
lieu dont nous avons connaissance mais
nous ne sommes pas les instigateurs
c'est intéressant un petit peu comme
c'est un secret je ne sais pas
honnêtement j'ai pas les informations
j'imagine bien que nous suivons quand
même de très près ce qui se passe on
sait qu'il ya des livraisons d'armes aux
rebelles les rebelles ne manquent pas
d'armes il manque de certaines armes
mais certaines armes dont ils manquent
est-ce que c'est nous qui délivreront
est ce que c'est la france les stocks de
l'armée française qui vont alimenter les
rebelles ce qui veut dire que nous
serons partie prenante au conflit avec
toutes les conséquences que cela peut
avoir
au niveau régional au liban sur nos
casques bleus en matière de terrorisme
est-ce qu'on laissera en fermera les
yeux sur des livraisons d'armes sensible
par d'autres pays sont des questions
éminemment compliqué et je crois que la
réponse que nous apportons
l'union européenne est une mauvaise
réponse mais qu'est ce qu'il aurait
fallu faire parce que là on a vu ce qui
s'est passé donc en début de semaine des
discussions marathon on vient de le voir
avec cette décision qui est une en fait
une non décision puisque de toute façon
dans l'embargo allait tomber
quelle aurait été selon vous l'attitude
la bonne attitude de l'europe
je crois que la bonne attitude de
l'europe sort était de passer la journée
et la soirée de lundi comme ça a été le
cas pour la levée de l'embargo
plutôt que de s'étriper sur des arguties
juridiques sur le régime de l'embargo je
pense qu'il aurait fallu passer la
journée et la soirée a essayé de se
mettre d'accord à 27 sur une ligne
politique et diplomatique à faire valoir
dans la fameuse conférence qui va
arriver entre russes et américains à
genève sur la syrie c'est une question
très importante c'est un rendez vous
très importante je ne connais pas la
ligne européenne
faut-il inviter l'iran ou ne faut-il pas
invité l'iran voilà une question qui est
au moins aussi sensible que celle de
l'embargo footing discuter avec bachar
ou faut-il leur retraite bachar comme
préalable à la négociation
voilà des positions extrêmement
importante pour la recherche d'une
solution politique sur laquelle il n'y a
pas de lignes européennes bien
consolider j'aurais aimé qu'on se
concentre sur ces sujets qui est fautif
dans ce sens un peu tout le monde vous
savez c'est trop facile de jeter la
pierre à madame ashton parce qu'elle n'a
pas su dégager un consensus en épargnant
les états membres qui sont très jaloux
de leurs prérogatives en matière de
diplomatie et défense
donc tout le monde a sa part de
responsabilité il faudrait sans doute un
leadership européen plus fort mais ceux
du marché européen plus fort n'est
possible que si les états membres
l'acceptent et jouent le jeu donc tout
le monde est un peu fautif j'ai
l'impression simplement qu'on se chaque
état vient avec sa propre revendications
sa propre aux priorités sans vraiment
regarder le
l'image l'image globale et surtout
d'image que tout cela dégage à
l'extérieur on attendait justement
l'europe unie en tout cas de l'extérieur
à un moment important et encore une fois
c'est une image quand même de désunion
qui est donné ce que la diplomatie
européenne que beaucoup appellent de
leurs voeux depuis des décennies
maintenant est ce que cette diplomatie
aujourd'hui est une utopie n'ont pas
totalement parce que quand même des
choses qui se font
je crois que il faut être réaliste on a
27 états membres
c'est la richesse et l'originalité du
projet européen de se faire aussi avec
des états des états nations et de ne pas
renier cette réalité là et en matière de
diplomatie et de défense c'est le coeur
de la souveraineté
donc c'est les domaines les plus
sensibles donc il faut pas s'étonner à
chaque fois qu'on n'est pas des
positions communes spontanée pour autant
il ya des choses qui sont l'union
européenne n'est pas totalement
inactives je pense notamment sur le plan
humanitaire et un travail absolument
colossal qui est fait avec la turquie
avec la jordanie avec le liban
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se font
bien sûr sur les décisions les plus
spectaculaires déjà lire parfois les
plus polémiques
la première chose qu'on regarde c'est ce
qu'il ya unité ou pas l'union européenne
et tout de suite on va pointer des
dissensions mais ces dissensions sont
pas totalement anormale et illégitime
c'est qu'en europe il ya en gros deux
deux pays qui ont de vraies forces
armées c'est la grande bretagne à la
france où le moulin vert ce que vous
voulez est ce que on n'aurait pas pu
souhaiter puisque là elles sont ces deux
puissances ont sont unis sont à peu près
sur la même position
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu souhaiter
qu'ils aient un effet d'entraînement sur
les 25 autres pays européens oui mais
vous noterez que d'autres pays font
valoir des considérations qui sont tout
aussi légitime je pense notamment à
l'autriche qui a beaucoup pesé sur ces
négociations parce que notre riche à
près de 400 militaires déployés sur le
plateau du golan dans une force de l'onu
et l'autriche craint légitimement pour
ses soldats déployés ces soldats neutre
déployés sur le plateau du golan
donc vous voyez que chacun a de bons
arguments aussi à faire valoir en tout
cas la plupart des pays qui sont
impliqués dans la région à un degré ou
un autre ont des bons arguments à faire
valoir
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre totalement
la logique de la de la position franco
britannique
si ce n'est pour réduire un peu
brutalement se donner bonne conscience
montrer que nous n'avons pas rien fait
face au drame syrien
c'est respectable moralement je pense
que politiquement c'est beaucoup plus ni
tiges yeux dernière question arnaud
danjean l'un des arguments de l'autriche
et d'autres pays européens s'étaient
dire l'europe a toujours été un facteur
de paix d'ailleurs l'europe a reçu
récemment le prix nobel de la paix et en
aucun cas elle doit être un élément de
guerre en livrant des armes est ce que
ça c'est quelque chose que vous partagez
je me méfie de cet argument qui consiste
à dire on ne joue que sur le soft power
comme on dit en bon français
attention l'union européenne doit aussi
être capable de montrer ses muscles le
cas échéant en l'occurrence les muscles
français ou anglais
et là encore ça renvoie à la question de
fond ces interventions militaires ou pas
intervention militaire
la levée de l'embargo c'est une formule
un peu bâtarde pour éviter de prendre
complètement ses responsabilités sur le
plan militaire tout en donnant
l'impression de faire quelque chose qui
se veut décisif mais qui ne sera
malheureusement pas merci beaucoup
arnaud danjean d'avoir
bondues à nos questions alors
l'actualité cette semaine en europe eh
bien ça a été l'étonnement d'un certain
nombre d'européens qui ont vu un pays la
suède s'embraser au cours de cinq nuits
d'émeutes alors dans un instant nous
allons recevoir une consoeur une
journaliste suédoise ici à bruxelles
mais tout de suite nous allons regarder
ce zapping des télévisions européennes à
propos de l'actuel regarder d'habitude
lorsqu'on évoque la suède on pense
plutôt réussite scolaire ou bien-être
mais là ce sont bien les violences
urbaines qui font les gros titres et
partout les mêmes images
la scène se répète des jeunes de la
banlieue de stockholm incendient des
voitures et brisé des vitres hier soir
c'est un commissariat qu'après feu dans
un autre quartier un peu plus au sud
cinquante jeunes ont lancé des pierres
en direction de la police
ailleurs dans le pays à malmö deux
voitures ont été incendiées sur tous les
écrans les habitants témoignent d'un
ras-le-bol évident et sur bien des
sujets nous avons une société dure ici
en suède avec beaucoup de chômage et une
éducation qui n'est pas de qualité dans
les écoles publiques
les gens ne peuvent pas avoir une vie
décente alors c'est tout un pays qui se
remettent en question le modèle suédois
n'a plus vraiment la cote
on a une explosion des idées à une
incroyable explosion de violence qui a
ouvert le débat sur la politique de la
jeunesse et la gestion de l'immigration
dans un pays qui se félicite de la
réputation de sa justice sociale
alors là pour ce zapping des télévisions
européennes signent et aurélie da face
avec nous sur ce plateau teresa kuchler
bonjour je vous êtes journaliste
suédoise vous êtes ici à bruxelles
depuis huit ans pour un grand quotidien
suédois qui s'appelle c'est un scanner
planète ce qui signifie est le quotidien
suédois
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce
que nous honnêtement quand on a vu ces
images qui nous arrivait de stockholm on
a tous été un petit peu surpris
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans ce pays
dans votre pays
selon lorsqu'elle passait il ya deux
semaines à peu près il ya eu un incident
il ya eu une confrontation entre des
policiers et un homme de 69 ans dans la
banlieue de stockholm dans ce quartier
qui s'appelle ville et cette personne
donc un homme dont le nom n'est pas
connu
il a menacé la police avec ashley
imagine h sur un grand couteau elle donc
la police ils ont tiré une balle
il est mort dans ce sociaux oui donc les
deux proteste il ya eu des prothèses sûr
que le fait que la police n'avait pas
tiré sur le chemin nous comme les lieux
devenus de vrais
et donc ils sas a déclenché beaucoup de
rumeurs sur la comporte le comportement
de la police dans ce quartier en général
il ya eu des débatteurs disons que le
policier la police dans ce quartier il
vise les gens il demande la carte
identité peut rien
donc ça commençait un débat sur la
police est ce que c'est un quartier où
il ya beaucoup de personnes d'origine
immigrée
oui c'est ça le problème en fait non est
ce que ça peut jouer dans le dire et
dans la la la violence des dans le sens
où peut-être que les gens de ce quartier
se sentent déjà un peu mise à part et
que c'était une sorte de de colère qui
s'exprime et là c'est plutôt que
l'ethnicité en soi bien sûr oui c'est un
quartier où par exemple statistiques des
réussites scolaires est très laid
réussite sans basse il ya beaucoup de
chômage surtout les jeunes presque 40%
des jeunes qui vont me à l'université à
aux écoles août ni travail donc oui ça
peut jouer
est ce que ça dit quelque chose ces
incidents qui se sont d'ailleurs terminé
maintenant est ce que ça dit quelque
chose sur le modèle d'intégration
on parle beaucoup de la suède comme
étant un modèle de réussite par exemple
sur le plan scolaire aussi est-ce que ça
ça du coup ça ça remet en cause des
choses chez vous voyez voilà ça c'est le
débat qui est qui et qui a commencé
depuis ces événements je pense que comme
comme on l'a vu
très les maîtres à londres et à paris il
ya une tendance bien sûr de regarder de
ceux qui regardent loin par exemple les
français ou les anglais mais ils font
une analyse sociologique la ségrégation
isolement alors que ceux qui sont dans
les événements les suédois ils ont
tendance à dire non c'est de la violence
inutile ça rien à voir ça c'est des
voyous ce sont des gens des certaines
malfaiteurs et donc mais oui bien sûr le
débat maintenant et sur la ségrégation
la l'intégration et les problèmes qui
peuvent vous qui êtes européenne et en
plus en poste ici à bruxelles vous
pensez que ce qui s'est passé en suède
trouve un écho j'ai envie de dire dans
ce qui se passe dans d'autres pays
est ce que c'est il ya je dirais ça tout
se reproduire ailleurs
mais je crois je crois que le chômage et
est un problème mondial repeint européen
je pense que le fait que ces jeunes
n'ont pas beaucoup à faire avec leur
journée on part de l'échec des écoles ça
c'est peut-être le grand débat qui va
mener un grand débat de l'échec des
écoles je pense maintenant après deux
semaines quand ils les médias ce recul
on peut joindre la lys c'est les écoles
qu'on débat maintenant
merci beaucoup teresa que je l'air
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on va
rester évidemment dans le domaine
européen vous savez que l'an prochain
pardon dans quelques semaines maintenant
l'union européenne ne sera plus 27 mai
mais 28 puisque la croatie va entrer
dans l'europe et nous nous avons voulu
savoir ce qui se passait en turquie ce
pays qui est aux portes de l'europe
depuis presque les années 60 est-ce
qu'il ya toujours un sentiment européen
et pro-européen là bas regardez c'est un
reportage qui est signée fabrice qu'une
et à istanbul et ensuite nous retrouvons
germain andrieu et son invité regarder
istanbul la plus européenne des villes
de turquie
un carrefour de cultures un pied sur le
vieux continent et la tête en asie ici
l'idée d'une adhésion à l'europe prend
parfois tout son sens
l'entreprise de mouradia ça en est une
parfaite illustration
sa spécialité les arômes pour
l'industrie alimentaire écossais
allemands autrichiens
on a beaucoup donc si vous voulez on est
rentier on a formé notre propre
communauté européenne
si la turquie ne fait pas partie de
l'union des accords existent déjà en
matière douanière ou comme ici en
matière sanitaire dont ces flacons des
centaines d'arômes tous aux normes
européennes alors l'adhésion à l'europe
mouradia ça y croit il faut décider si
l'europe c'est une europe
ross antique chrétien ou c'est une
europe qui est prête à partager ses
voyages avec la candidate cultive qui
attend l'adhésion à l'europe
nous vous y croyez mais s'il ya dans
l'urne était témoin jj quoi
l'honnêteté de l'europe l'adhésion à
l'union en turquie peu de gens y croient
encore
et particulièrement la jeune génération
dans un récent sondage 62% des 16-30 ans
n'ont plus confiance pour berra mais ses
amis
la question fait débat il ya du pour et
du contre
on ne peut pas vraiment le dire avant
mais je pense que nous devons intégrer
l'europe et ensuite on verra bien non
non moi je ne veux pas je suis contre
l'entrée dans l'europe
je suis né en allemagne donc je sais ce
que ça signifie de vivre dans un pays
européen
il ya la crise économique le chômage a
augmenté avec l'euro et on a perdu du
pouvoir d'achat
je pense que la turquie n'a pas besoin
de l'europe
au contraire c'est la zone euro qui a
besoin de nous je pense que si on arrête
les négociations aujourd'hui c'est
l'europe qui viendra frapper à notre
porte
ce processus a vraiment été trop lance
les premières discussions ont débuté
dans les années 60 une longue procédure
que certaines universités explique dans
des cours de droit et d'histoire
européen
le professeur safety ngure sel et
directeur de l'un de ces départements le
problème de la turquie ne sait pas qui
sont musulmans mais ce qu'ils soient
trop grand dans le passion disent aussi
trop grand trop peau maintenant on dit -
troppo étant donné la situation en
europe et vu le progrès la croissance en
turquie etc
mais il est trop grand il reste aux
grands et on n'y peut rien
en clair la turquie dans l'union ce
serait plus de députés que la france et
presque autant que l'allemagne alors
trop grand ou trop musulman
une chose est sûre lassé d'attendre le
pays se tournent de plus en plus vers
les pays du golfe à m suze a ses entrées
à bruxelles pour ce chef d'entreprise
si l'avenir de son pays et à l'est il
n'y voit pas un frein à une adhésion
c'est important pour la turquie de
s'imposer comme le pays phare de la
région et d'un autre côté il faut tout
aussi intéressant pour l'europe avec
intégré dans l'union la tuerie au et son
influence locale
si les médias turcs eux sont
eurosceptiques un journal fait de la
résistance et défend l'idée d'une
adhésion
donc ça c'est une idée de l'interview
pour numéro 100 mais pour la rédactrice
en chef
l'europe fait le jeu du pouvoir
conservateur en place en turquie en
freinant les négociations un jeu
dangereux
depuis plusieurs années il n'y a qu'un
seul chapitre iv et les autres les plus
importants ce qui permet une intégration
effectifs sont bloqués donc ça c'est en
fin de compte c'est quelque chose à
double tranchant d'une part ça donne un
très bon prétexte pour le pouvoir en
place en 10 ans on voyait c'est pas nous
c'est eux parce que si nous bloque et
d'autre part quelque part ça les arrange
aussi parce qu'en fin de compte d'objets
leur objectif n'est pas véritablement de
faire des avancées rapides pour les
partisans d'une turquie européenne
l'adhésion donnerait des garanties pour
l'avenir démocratique du pays
un droit de regard pas forcément du goût
du pouvoir en place
dernier signe d'agacement le premier
ministre erdogan a récemment fixé un
ultimatum à l'europe
la question devrait être tranchée d'ici
à 2023
voilà pour ce reportage à istanbul signé
fabrice qu'une m et in kazakh nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes député européen
vous êtes vulgaire mais également
d'origine turque alors on l'a vu dans ce
reportage avec la turquie et l'europe ça
fonctionne déjà il ya des accords en
matière douanière les échanges
commerciaux fonctionne est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas rester dans ce statu quo
oui c'est tout à fait vrai l'histoire
comme commune entre l'europe et la
turquie se dote depuis des années
c'est vrai qu'on avançait sur le domaine
du commerce des échanges et on a on a eu
pas mal de progrès on a eu pas mal de
succès mais bon ça ne suffit pas à ce
que la turquie elle est candidate à
l'adhésion de l'europe depuis des
décennies déjà
et surtout la dernière année on a
l'impression que ce processus est à
l'arrêt et c'est c'est se créer des
frustrations nous côté tueur que du côté
européen aussi parce que il y a quand
même des avantages de l'adhésion de la
turquie qui semble n'être et on a vu
justement ce reportage les jeunes
commencent à douter un les chiffres
c'est 62 % des 16-30 ans et bien
commencent à se lasser de cette adhésion
ce processus qui s'éternise vous vous le
comprenez c'est s'inquiétant que la
jeunesse turquie bien commence à douter
oui parce que comme j'ai dit ce
processus est à la traîne et ans de plus
quand on entend depuis quelques années
des messages de la part des hommes et
les femmes politiques européennes qui
sont contre l'adhésion de la turquie qui
sont qui sont en fait
en faveur d'une manière alternatif
d'approfondissement des relations autre
que l'adhésion pleine et entière
bien sûr ça crée des frustrations et
sacré à une méfiance au sein de la
société turque surtout des jeunes alors
on dit souvent attention la turquie
pourrait se tourner plus vers les pays
du golfe
néanmoins les exportations de la turquie
pour près de moitié ont pour destination
l'europe donc finalement est ce que les
pays du golfe ça peut suffire la turquie
la turquie
est-ce qu'elle a autant besoin de
l'europe que l'europe a besoin la
turquie oui en fait la turquie comme
vous le savez elles se trouvent entre
l'europe et l'asie et le la des
territoires sur les deux continents
elle joue le pont entre l'europe et
l'asie
donc c'est normal qu'elles qu'elles
essayent d'avoir des relations aussi
bien avec l'europe qu'est les pays du
golfe les pilotes du monde au
moyen-orient mais bien sûr la vocation
européenne de la turquie
c'est clair et net donc la turquie et
elle a toujours exprimé sa volonté de
devenir un membre un jour de l'union
européenne et je crois que 7,7
cette volonté et prouver par des actes
récents des actes concrets du pouvoir en
carats dans le domaine des réformes
constitutionnelles administratifs qui
sont en compte qu'ils sont donc qui vont
dans le sens de l'accomplissement des
critères de copenhague
effectivement le processus d'adhésion
est engagée depuis longtemps en revanche
elle est candidate officielle depuis
on est en 2013 aujourd'hui est ce que
vous pensez que la turquie pourrait
abandonner ce processus d'adhésion
exclusivement pour se tourner vers les
pays du golfe
est-ce que ça c'est probable moi je
crois pas je crois que
donc la turquie elle n'a pas aussi une
alternative
je crois que d'ailleurs tous les
intérêts pas seulement commerciaux mais
bon il ya une grande partie de la
population turque ihh a qui vit aussi en
europe déjà il ya beaucoup d turquie vit
dans l'europe il ya des relations
culturelles économiques politiques qui
sont fortes
donc je crois que la turquie elle va
poursuivre sa démarche de continuer les
réformes et de pousser les dirigeants
les leaders européens à faire accepter
dans les consciences cependant dans
l'opinion publique européenne que la
turquie elle doit elle peut elle doit
devenir membre de l'union alors ça c'est
pour du côté turc mais du côté européen
comment vous expliquez que sondage après
sondage est bien une majorité des pays
européens
et bien soit contre l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'union européenne
comment vous expliquez un petit peu ce
frein est ce qu'il ya des raisons
peut-être culturel ce que vous
reconnaissez peut-être on a parlé de
racines chrétiennes à l'europe est ce
que ça peut être un frein par rapport à
l'identité aux turcs
oui en période de crise économique et
sociale
il est vrai que un petit peu dans tous
les pays de l'europe donc les jdr un
petit peu
nationaliste les idées de fermeture et
idée de comment dirais-je de trouver un
bouc émissaire de tous et de tous ses
maux bien tentante de montrer quelqu'un
qui est différent du point de vue
culturel religieuses comme une menace
éventuelle de l'identité du coup et
c'est de l'europe mais je crois que dès
que cette crise soit donc fini je crois
que l'idée de l'europe qui est même qui
est dans son logo c'est l'unité dans la
diversité
elle trouve en elle même que bon on peut
pas faire des discriminations pour
l'adhésion d'une telle telle pays par
rapport à la religion dominante dans ce
livre lorient - défait ce que les
valeurs communes de l'europe sont
vraiment respecté par la turquie la
liberté d'expression la liberté de la
presse notamment et qui a encore besoin
de faire plus d'efforts de la part de la
turquie
oui certainement et ce assez
on le souligne à chaque fois qu'on ici
au parlement européen nous adoptons
notre rapport régulier sur l'état
d'avancement de la turquie bien sûr que
la question de la liberté de la presse
l'ebita de la liberté d'expression et
encore est accordée dès le départ à
faire en turquie en cours des choses à
faire mais bon ça c'est un processus qui
est bon moi je crois que le gouvernement
en place
il fait des efforts je crois que ils
tous les autres partis doivent soutenir
ses démarches il faut qu'il y ait un
consensus pour sein de la société turque
on doit avancer sur ce sur ce point
parce que la turquie ne pourra pas avoir
un donc avoir une place qu'elle le
mérite
s'il n'avance pas sur le domaine des
droits de l'homme mais selon vous vous
pensez que tous les sujets peuvent être
mis sur la table comme la reconnaissance
du génocide arménien on se souvient de
tension entre paris et ankara
il ya quelques mois est ce que ce genre
de sujets peuvent peut également être
mis sur la table
oui ça c'était ce sont toujours des
questions controversées
bon je crois que la turquie et l'union
doivent se concentrer surtout sur le
processus d'adhésion lui même c'est à
dire sur le plan donc qui est de
de route qui est adoptée sur l'ouverture
des champs leur appel à treize chapitres
sont ouverts un seul est clos il ya
encore beaucoup de travail pour conclure
le point l'avantagent de la turquie pour
cette adhésion européenne qu'il est son
point fort quel est son point faible
selon vous en en deux mots oui le point
fort c'est donc la situation
géostratégique de la turquie son pouvoir
économique et donc son passé sont source
d'inspiration pour les autres pays de la
région surtout du moyen-orient et sombre
est faible 1 faible qu'on vous l'avez
mentionné c'est toujours c'est la
question des droits de l'homme la
liberté d'expression le pluralisme
là il ya encore 2 donc la réforme
judiciaire et constitutionnel
ce sont vraiment des mesures concrètes
que le gouvernement restera et bien
merci un meeting kazakh d'avoir été avec
nous et d'avoir répondu à nos questions
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici à
bruxelles avec kathia gilder et françois
beaudonnet en attendant bones une des
programmes et à très bientôt sur les
chaînes parlementaires